[Music]
for russia the war in ukraine has been a
disaster
in just over two months around 15 000
soldiers have been killed
including an estimated 10 generals
at least 1 800 armored vehicles have
been destroyed
[Music]
and the attempt to take over the capital
kiev was a chaotic failure resulting in
a humiliating retreat
so what's wrong with the russian army
there's a debate swirling among western
military officers experts officials as
to why the russian army has done so
badly in ukraine and part of the answer
is they were set up to fail they were
told to invade ukraine and they were
told that the country would collapse
quickly so they didn't plan properly and
they initially attempted a botched
effort at regime change with a very
lightly armed force but then what we saw
when the russian army did invade in
large numbers was a campaign that was
not only planned very badly but also
executed very badly we saw tactical
errors we saw low morale we saw a
russian air force that was nearly absent
from the campaign in modern armies the
principle of jointness is really valued
and that means army air force navy and
other branches like cyber forces
electronic warfare and and marines all
working hand in glove
russia's army has shown that it isn't
any good at that russian troops out
there in the field facing ukrainians are
not getting the kind of air support that
a american ground force or a british
ground force would enjoy from the air
one factor that we have to bear in mind
is that russia's army does not have a
layer of what in western armies we call
non-commissioned officers or ncos this
is a layer of of men or women who are
senior enlisted personnel they're not
officers uh but they are sort of
enlisted men who have been in the force
for many years and supervise train and
discipline the uh privates the the
people under them this is a vital layer
of leadership for instilling discipline
in any western army the russian army
doesn't have it and i think we are
seeing the consequences of that in
ukraine today
russia's army has always had a fairly
brutal way of warfare we saw this in
afghanistan in the 1980s in chechnya in
the 1990s and early 2000s and of course
in their intervention in support of
bashar al-assad syria's dictator from
2015 and we have now seen it again in
evidence of war crimes in places like
bucha a suburb of kiev and other parts
of ukraine there are probably two
reasons for brutality one of them is
that it can be instrumental it can be a
way of terrorizing the civilian
population to make it easier to control
them to subdue any kind of resistance or
revolt
the other fact of course is that this is
a undisciplined army uh there are
conscripts who are young 18 year olds
perhaps from far away parts of russia
who were never told they were going to
ukraine let alone to fight and have
found themselves uh in these scenarios
in these situations uh very poorly led
uh they are being fed rations that may
be expired they are cold they may be
hungry they may be demoralized and they
may have suffered grave casualties
in those conditions under those
circumstances it's no surprise that an
army may resort to abuses that it may
turn itself and turn its weapons onto
the civilian population a poorly led
army an undisciplined army is not just a
poor fighting force it's also a hazard
to the civilians amongst whom it fights
the battle for the donbass region that
is now unfolding is absolutely critical
for both sides if russia fails to make
significant gains in donbass over the
next few weeks
it will constitute a strategic failure
for the russian army and indeed the
combat power of the russian army will be
spent it will have suffered too many
casualties too much attrition to mount
another attack on kiev or other cities
and i think vladimir putin will then be
facing a difficult and unpalatable and
indeed a dangerous choice between
backing down and giving up on ukraine or
conducting a national mobilization of
manpower and equipment and resources and
escalating in the country so that is
what makes this next few weeks so vital
for ukraine for russia and for the west
thank you for watching for all our
coverage on the war in ukraine please
click on the link and don't forget to
subscribe
you